what has happened in chemistry is that
there has been this inertia of people
doing chemistry the same way for
hundreds of years because it's this is a
model of apprenticeship the advice or
tells the student how to do things the
student doesn't really question if
that's the right way of doing or not so
we're doing in this program is saying
well wait a second why do you in the
fourth Industrial Revolution we have all
these new tools especially artificial
intelligence and robotics that can
transform the way we do science so
functionally we are we're gonna change
the scientific discovery process you
know this is not about the simple
hypothesis driven research loops of
iteration it'sit's about fundamentally
challenging how we go about the
scientific discovery process in chemical
space is believe that you know
developing a new material takes about
ten million dollars in ten years roughly
order of magnitude why it is because all
these chemistry is done by hand and is
done in a very time inefficient fashion
several areas of science have been
transformed by the use of machinery the
focus of what we're talking here is
really building out the tools platforms
and methods of how we go into chemical
discovery but that's the thing chemistry
sits as a central science to almost
anything health materials energy so
we're talking about not only changing
how one goes and does discovery in
chemical science but the feedback that
the spill off from that means we can
affect things like energy storage energy
conversion from solar new pharmaceutical
drugs new textiles what are the things
that we want is that any educated or
trained person that has a molecular
dream that imagines a potential solution
to a problem in the world has easy
access to a machine that we could call
it like a molecular maker lab that you
write what molecule you want and it will
tell you what are the reagents that you
need it will put them together makes
more quantities of this material and
then go and test it know people new to
the Seafarer program don't really what
know what to make of it it's the first
time we've heard of it
the thing that's enabling about this is
it's allowing us to break down borders
and really put many different people in
the same room and giving them free rein
to discuss you know this is this is
giving people the opportunity to
to make these sort of connections
long-standing connections and also again
it provides a flag for people to rally
around that we are CFR fellows
[Music]
you